اا اخر المستجدات في حي سلوان مع نجوان
كما ذكرت سابقا هادئ لكن على توتر بعد ان
انسحبت قوات الاحتلال من هذا الموقع حيث
وقعت عمليه اطلاق النار سبح هذا اليوم
تحديدا عند هذا المنزل البؤره الاستيطانيه
المنزل العربي الذي استولى عليه مستوطنون
سابقا بحسب روايه الاحتلال فان الطفل او
الفتى محمد عليوات هو المتهم بتنفيذ هذه
العمليه وقام باطلاق النار باتجاه مجموعه
من المستوطنين في هذا الموقع من خلال مسدس
كان بحوزته العائله نفت ذلك همم كليا لكن
قبل قليل اكدت المصادر الطبيه الاسرائيليه
بان الطفل الفتى يخضع لعلاج بعد ان اصيب
باطلاق نار من احد المستوطنين الذين كانوا
يتواجدون في هذا الموقع هو في مستشفى
هداسا في التقتها رهتسوفيم وليس في عين
كارم كما تم ابلاغ المحامي في وقت سابق
وحالته توصف
بالمتوسطه الى الخطره لكنها مستقره ال-
احد المصابين في هذه العمليه من
المستوطنين هو جندي من وحده ضابط في الجيش
الاسرائيلي عمليا من وحده
المظليين لكنه في اجازه اي انه لم يكن كان
عمليا كان مدنيا لانه لم يكن همم في اطار
الخدمه العسكريه في هذا الموقع وهو من قام
باطلاق النار وكما نشاهد عده مركبات في
هذا الموقع
اصيبت باطلاق الرصاص ما ادى الى تكسر
الزجاج في هذا الموقع نتحدث عن تعزيزات
للشرطه الاسرائيليه في عده محاور طرق هنا
في القدس تحديدا عندما داخل الاحياء
والبلدات الفلسطينيه في القدس المحتله تم
اقتحام قبل قليل انزل هذا الطفل هذا الفتى
في حي عين اللوزي في سلوان ليس بعيدا من
هنا وتم اعتقال افراد هي اسرته بحسب
المصادر والديه
وشقيقه ايضا وهذا ايضا ما حدث في بلده
الطور عند منزل من تتهمه سلطات الاحتلال
بتنفيذ عمليه الليله الماضيه في الحي
الاستيطاني نافي يعقوب المفتش العام
للشرطه كان قد اعلن صباح اليوم عن رفع
حاله التاهب الى الدرجه القصوى سواء كان
في القدس او في المناطق الاخرى في الضفه
الغربيه هناك تعزيز لقوات الشرطه بوحده
دائما تعزز القوات المتواجده سواء كان من
الوحدات الخاصه او الوحدات حرس الحدود
وحده اليمامه وهي وحده خاصه في الشرطه
الاسرائيليه عاده ما يتم استدعائها عند
وجود مواجهات عنيفه او عمليات كبيره سيتم
المتواجده بشكل دائم من هذه الوحده هذا
بالاضافه الى تعزيزات اخرى ايضا اعلن عنها
صباحا اليوم جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بكتيبه كامله الى منطقه الضفه الغربيه
وبالتالي هذا يعني بان اسرائيل تتجهز ربما
لحاله من التصعيد لا سيما وانه تم الاعلان
ايضا قبل قليل عن عده اجراءات يتوقع ان
يطرحها رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياه خلال
جلسه المجلس الامني والوزاري المصغر التي
ستعقد هذه الليله في تل ابيب كانت تم
تعيينها الليله الماضيه في عقاب عمليه
نفيق ولكن ايضا حاليا هذا التصعيد في
مدينه القدس هناك عده نقاط ولكن يعني لو
لو اشير اليها سريعا التقدم في تشريع
قانون لطرد عائلات منفذي العمليات ويسميهم
الاعلام الاسرائيلي بطبيعه الحال المخربين
نيجيين اغلاق وهدم فوري لمنازل منفذيه
العمليات اعتقال افراد عائلته اقرباء
منفذي العمليات تعزيز قوات الجيش في
الدفاع الغربيه وتسريع عمليه منح تراخيص
حمل السلاح للاسرائيليين ولو اردنا التطرق
لكل نقطه ونقطه فهذا هو المتبع منذ سنوات
عده عمليه الهدم لمنازل من يقومون بتنفيذ
او يتهمون بتنفيذ عمليات ضد اهداف
اسرائيليه يتم هدم المنازل واغلاقها لكن
في بعض الاحيان يكون هناك اجراء قضائي في
المحاكم الاسرائيليه التي غالبا تقرر
وتصدق على قرار جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بهدم هذه المنازل الان سيتم فقط تسريع هذه
العمليه بحيث يتم الهدم او اغلاق المنازل
بشكل فوري وقضيه ايضا سحب او طرد عائلات
منفذ العمليات من مناطق القدس ايضا هذا
اجراء متبعه هناك عده عائلات فلسطينيه في
القدس المحتله اا تخوض معالق قضائيه بعد
ان التهم التهم احد افراد الاسره بتنفيذ
عمليه يتم سحب اقامات هذه العائلات من
مدينه القدس وترضها الى الضفه الى مناطق
اخرى في الضفه الغربيه قضيه تسريع عمليه
منح الاسلحه للاسرائيليين كان ايضا قد
اعلن عنها قبل نحو عامين عند عمليه سيف
القدس بعد احداث حي الشيخ جراح حينها من
بدر الى ذلك كان رئيس الحكومه السابق بنت
وكان بين كبير دائما وزير الامن القومي
الحالي يحرض على ذلك على ضروره تسلح
الاسرائيليين واستخدامهم للسلاح في اي
موقع يشبه به تنفيذ عمليه لكن في بعض
الاحيان هناك اجراءات تتعلق بماضي الاشخاص
الذين يقدمون على طلب تراخيص سلاح مثل
الماضي جنائي او ما الى ذلك هذا يستغرق
وقت اكثر ولكن بحسب الاجراءات الجديده قد
يتم منع حتى هؤلاء الاسلحه
ضمن ما دعى اليه الليله الماضيه لتمار بني
كفير حسن ابقي